لدى إد ويدمان أحدث حظر والأشخاص الذين
هم في أمس الحاجة إلى إجابات بالطبع ،
لكن تحديات التحقيق في هذا الأمر
واضحة جدًا اليوم
نعم من الواضح جدًا أن جوليا هناك
قوى داخل لبنان لا تريد أن
ترى هذا التحقيق
يمضي قدمًا في هذا
العنف الذي استغرق  مكان اليوم في
بيروت هو أسوأ ما شهدته العاصمة اللبنانية منذ
سنوات ، اندلع عندما اندلع احتجاج نظمه
حزب الله وعمان حزبان شيعيان
لهما أيضًا
ميليشيات احتجاجا على طارق بهتار ،
وهو القاضي الذي تم تعيينه
للتحقيق في تفجير 4 أغسطس
2020.  خلف أكثر من 2200
قتيل الآن ، أراد استجواب علي
حسن خليل ، وزير المالية
السابق المنتسب إلى حركة أمل
، وكان
الوزير خليل
قد تقدم بشكوى قانونية
ضد القاضي
متهماً إياه بالتحيز صباح يوم الخميس
أمام المحكمة.
نفى
تقديم شكوى قانونية في هذا الاحتجاج
واندلاع حريق من
المباني المحيطة على المؤيد  المختبرين
في هذه المرحلة نفهم من
الصليب الأحمر اللبناني أن ستة أشخاص
قتلوا أكثر من 30 جريحًا
وما سمعناه من حزب الله وأمل
أنهم كانوا يتهمون القوات اللبنانية
بحزب مسيحي لديه
أيضًا ميليشيا بوضع قناصة على
هؤلاء.  المباني وإطلاق النار على
المتظاهرين الآن حدث هذا في منطقة
قريبة جدًا من حيث بدأت الجولات الافتتاحية
للحرب الأهلية اللبنانية
في أبريل
1975 والعديد من المشاهد التي رأيناها
اليوم تذكرنا بأن الأطفال
المتجمعين تحت مكاتب في المدارس
أناس مدنيون يفرون منها.  المنطقة التي
حاول الجيش اللبناني إعادة
السيطرة عليها في المنطقة محذرا من أنه
سيفتح النار على أي شخص
يطلق النار في تلك المنطقة ويطلب من
المدنيين المغادرة في أسرع وقت
ممكن الآن التقى رئيس الوزراء اللبناني الجديد
نجيب بمسؤولين في الجيش.  وهو
يراقب الوضع
دعا
إلى الهدوء ولكن كما قلت هذا هو أسوأ
عنف شهدته بيروت منذ سنوات عديدة
وهذا هو الحال.  قلق بالغ
لدى سكان بيروت
يخشى الكثيرون أن تكون
هذه بداية جولة عنف
لم يشهدها لبنان
منذ نهاية
الحرب الأهلية في جوليا 1975-1990.